me pregunto ahora qué cambia un juicio
así para un país y para su población ya
habíamos visto en 2007 el juicio de los
atentados de madrid de 2004 los más
mortíferos que conoció europa hasta
ahora se pueden comparar
se pueden comparar desde el punto de
vista técnico y el punto de vista del
impacto social evidentemente aunque sólo
un poco
burdo entre 300 y 150 el impacto no es
tan relevante más que para las víctimas
para el estado sigue siendo un impacto
terrible y se acercan las posturas
procesales escuchando la conversación
que ustedes mantenían con sus
responsables hablaban de que esas penas
que han puesto a los no directamente
implicados pero sí coadyuvantes el
atentado podrían ser revisadas y podrían
ser minimizadas porque realmente eran 30
años de cumplimiento efectivo de condena
el derecho procesal francés es
extremadamente riguroso yo creo que en
estas operaciones que tienen su derecho
a hacer van a fracasar porque el seguro
ante el estado no les va a permitir el
abandono de las cárceles ni mucho menos
va a seguir el duro y que hemos
aprendido hemos aprendido a que no se
puede responder con buenismo a gente que
no entiende los principios democráticos
y que su objetivo fundamental es
deconstruir todas gracias y eliminar
subvertir el sistema de valores
constitucionales de este caso en francia
o en españa en su momento y esto es una
corriente que arrastra toda europa
esperemos no llegar a tener que utilizar
el derecho penal del enemigo porque
sería ya pasar ciertas fronteras incluso
para los constitucionalistas y
penalistas españoles franceses italianos
sería volver al siglo 18 entonces espero
no llegar a ello pero el camino está
marcado el camino es de dureza el camino
de firmeza el camino es de no vuelta
atrás el camino de vuelta atrás para las
visiones sobre lo que puede ocurrir
cuando una persona intenta hacer un
atentado terrorista esto también tiene
un problema y es que ahora los
terroristas están mucho más
concienciados de que una vez cárdenas de
todo terroristas tienen que triunfar
porque perder significa ir hacia toda la
vida en la cárcel y ser un ejemplo de la
disciplina jurídica de europa es decir
que podríamos afirmar que este tipo de
medidas que se adoptaron hoy son
suficientes son las adecuadas
son suficiente el punto de vista penal y
el punto vista administrativo de vista
procesal seguramente no son suficientes
nunca es suficiente para los que han
sufrido la pérdida de un familiar y
nunca es suficiente para restañar las
heridas que ha generado esta disrupción
en el estado de derecho son suficientes
probablemente sí porque son penas en las
que no hay
reinserción posible no hay disminución
de la condena por tanto son penas
efectivas que son equivalentes a una
condena perfecta de una persona que
tenga 30 años termina la condena con 60
años de civil ya no tiene posibilidad de
reinserción social y lo más probable que
se acabe en lugares de beneficiencia y
la gente que comete algún otro delito
dentro de la prisión seguirá aumentando
a esa condena a esa condena los años de
cárcel por tanto nos acercamos hacia
modelos como por ejemplo en eeuu en el
que la segunda implicación en un delito
lleva consigo la pena de cásico de
cadena perpetua como difícil redención
por tanto significa muchos indica mucho
hay que estudiarla
a la sentencia en profundidad y ver qué
es lo que ha cambiado el derecho
procesal francés es administrativa y de
hecho penal para conseguir saber hasta
qué punto está implicado un cambio
jurídico en la doctrina francesa ha
quedado tenía continental esquemas
privan en europa